Lịch kênh lại toàn nổ công tức chương và tĩ nhiệt.
Để cả gặp.
Được. Được trên nào.
Người à, ngôi ngồi màa, rồi đó, kết quả tốt.
Nha, bây giờ mắt đầu vào công tức xuống ổ.
Công thức bộ biến tiên nổi nào.
Nộ biến tiên nổi nào.
Nen tấu, bằng, à, gặp, quý.
Thánh nơi lại các em chính tính nửa nổi biến tiên nổi nào.
Tôi không tính nửa nổi nào ngôi bà.
Nha, mời trong công tức này, à mà công.
Cái gì?
Lôi khi không thì thì người ta không cho cái em.
Vậy thì mà ta hình như thế nào, không tính công.
Thì có các công tức tính công số đây trong màa này.
À, vậy thì tính công thì có các công tức xuống.
Nha, công tức nên ra nhất công mà màn dựa tắt vực lịch màn.
Nhan quán nửa vực truyền, nhan quốc của các em màn.
F-F-F-F, lắm, khổ công tức.
Không tức như ai, là cốc a được tính màn.
Độ biến tiên thế nào, nãy thế lăng đầu.
Chư đi thế lăng sau.
Tế năng sau.
À, thế năng này là mừng gặp vết một.
Chư đi mừng gặp vết.
Nhan, rồi.
Không tức xuống a.
Nè, tính công nâng.
Công a màn, nãy cơ năng đầu.
Chư đi cơ năng sau.
Nội, biến tiên cơ năng.
Tỉ bằng công, cũng mại lực, bắt được nè bà.
Nhưng mại thầy đã nói cho kẹm mà công dân, nãy tính công.
Săng đến tính nghiệp lượng.
Anh nghiệp lượng ấy thì các em anh rạc.
Hà kì công thuốc này.
Trong bà, công tức thứng nhất là nghiệp lượng quay thì bằng công xuất nghiệp thời gian.
À, công tức thời gian.
Mặc em anh rạc, mặc em đã đi.
Lý ta cho năng xuất bà yệt của yên lượng.
Thì cho năng xuất bà yệt của rau ấy của thà này là của khu dưới đó.
Thì yệt là quý được tính bằng.
Cũng được nhanh lăng xuất bà yệt.
Thầy nhắc anh, lấy khu dựa nhanh lăng xuất bà yệt.
Thì được anh yệt hợp.
Nhanh nhanh, bà kì, có ai còn tức thích yệt là này.
Các em anh nhanh.
Bây giờ, sáng đến một số ai là, bây giờ,
liên quan đến liệu xuất của đậm cửa yệt.
Nếu người ta cho biết, vượt nộ của năng xuất.
Thì, liệu xuất của đậm cửa yệt được bánh mạng.
Lấy lộ chắc là nghiệt nộ, dứa hành của năng xuất.
Chứa cho nghiệt nộ của năng.
Tức nộ như nộ của năng và tây hành như đồ của năng.
Là hồi này, công trong thích thăm phần nhé,
thì không nhé, rất là sao mà làm bài, đúng là.
Hồi, khi anh, kiểu xuất nửa tính màn công trí ở cho giết nộ của năng.
Nếu vậy, như vậy, cũng có một giết nộ của năng.
Nếu mà cái giết nộ này là, bị thủng cấp,
thì nãy bánh trí ở giết nộ.
Nhanh một chăm phần nhé.
Một công thích để tính giểu xuất nộ.
Nhanh lấy giết nộ, có ai,
quy có ai, cho ai, chia cho quy toàn phần nhé.
Một chăm phần nhé.
A trong thích, dính yếu xuất của nộ của giết nộ.
Tương á.